the French election has shaped up to be
what many people are considering a
replay of the 2016 US presidential
election comparing the centrist
neoliberal McCrone to Hillary Clinton
and the far-right xenophobic marine
lepen to Donald Trump it seems to be
shaping up as a referendum on
neoliberalism versus fascism and will
impact that that accusation of that
position in a moment but just to show
you some of the results emmanuel macron
got 29 23.9 percent of the vote which
was the largest share rounded up to
twenty-four percent on your screen
marine lepen guide 21.3 percent filion
twenty percent Melancon melon shown 19.6
percent and the rest are as you can see
we're not even remotely in the
competition melon shown is the far left
more of the socialist candidate even for
the left than Bernie Sanders but he was
compared to Bernie Sanders here in the
United States the one thing that stands
out about this to me though is that as
of today is so far today Melancon a
melon shown depending on who you ask has
not come out to endorse McCrone and he's
saying with McCrone that he's really
having to go back to his supporters pad
to figure out who he's going to support
here's the thing for me there should be
no she's my words there should be no
question who you support who used to
support right because marine lepen is
borderline a Holocaust denier 100%
xenophobic one hundred percent against
plurality any type of religious
plurality in each you know she has
demonstrated to be probably the worst if
you look at the try at the triumphant
day of Trump Nigel Farage marine lepen
she's probably the worst so I get
opposition to neoliberalism but we're
not talking we're talking about fascism
so for Melancon not to have endorse him
at this point really really bothers me
and I hate to compare this to the
American experience but it's just too
tempting it has a lot to do with the
people who were on Bernie side during
the primaries but were unwilling to back
Hillary during the general election
and the result of that ultimately was a
band that was far worse than Hillary
Clinton becoming president someone who
is far more right wing and here's the
logical fallacy of it all right so this
is going back to the original premise
which is the premise that people are
positing is that this is a referendum
between neoliberalism and fascism and
here's where I disagree with that right
if you take neoliberalism as economic
concept deregulation privatization
defunding the entire concept of the
public good if you take that as the
economic concept every single thing that
you hate about Hillary Clinton the same
things that you hate about Barack Obama
same things that you hate about McCrone
and France everything one of those
things is not only present in this
version of fascism its present in Donald
Trump present and Nigel Farage present
in marina pin but it's it's magnified
right it's like neoliberalism squared
with the added bonus of beautiful via
racism and no nationalism yeah and it's
hard for a lot of people to suck it up
and vote for a candidate who they have
many disagreements with but ultimately
is the lesser of two evils compared to
the two we'd like to think that McCrone
will be able to run all over marine
lepen in this runoff I think he's
pulling something like ten points higher
all the other defeated candidates will
probably back him right because given
the alternative he's just a much better
option but a lot of us had the same
hubris about Hillary Clinton where I
came back to our own election hi I'm
going to be honest with you I think
marine lepen is going to win and I hope
I'm wrong I hope I'm wrong I just see
the writing on the wall right it's hard
not to recognize the far right leaning
ethanol nationalism xenophobic movement
on the national stage on the
international stage and so and then if
we are comparing it to the 2016 election
it's the it's the competence you said
hubris but definitely hubris and
confidence / competence that that they
got it in the bag and so if they have
that overconfidence there and they have
not learned the lesson from Hillary
Clinton versus trump it's very very
likely that marine lepen will pull this
out and that would have major
consequences because marine lepen
becoming president of france would
probably mean France pulling out from
European Union and with France and the
UK out of the
you I think that's the end of the EU
that right which which if we look back
if if we were to fast-forward 50 years
and look at any international conflict
on the European continent we would be
able to trace the roots of that conflict
back to brexit and marine lepen
withdrawing France from the EU right
because this is this is one of the one
of the most important facets of the EU
has been their ability to keep wore off
of the European continent since its
foundation so this is why this is why
Melancon not endorsing McCrone at this
point is doubly disturbing to me for
many many reasons